yeah welcome a new video go play this
song in here in a 15 minute game online
[ __ ] and he goes for c3 yeah always
some slightly annoying move you're
looking forward to your open Sicilian of
choice and then none it only goes for 33
and um yeah just doesn't let you play
your night off or dragon or whatever you
intended ok applied d5 and let's see
what happens yeah d 5 is one of the two
most principled responses Knight f6 85
I'm done yeah like immediately gets a
room for ice pieces so here I think I'm
black has various choices you should g4
knight c6 e6 also g6 which I'm playing
here this has some slight resemblance to
some lines of the the English opening
white playing c4 and c5 and so on ok so
we go some you should be you three so
Whitley threatening to to actually take
this pawn yeah maybe he is should i
should i take on deform yeah the
constant very with taking or divorce
that what actually gets a temper with a
Nazi three you don't want to allow that
really but I'm not sure it's may be
threatening really to to take this of
course I can take on d1 and he loses the
right to Castle but still it's a pawn
okay I'll take them just claiming that
it doesn't matter really 93 I go Queen
85
yeah it's a bit of a concession maybe
not the best move but I wanted to avoid
this pawn down scenario was d take c5 I
don't think this should be a really
terrible for me I would be surprised if
a divot will it would be terrible vm
allows me to just castle and play I know
rook da 96 ok so an active Bishop
development here let's get castle first
can't do without that in the long run
yeah yeah this is interesting now should
our play Bishop g4 I shouldn't I
Bishop g4 may be surrendering the the
bishop after h3 I need to take really
but it would speed up my development a
bit knight c6 he can play a d5 handle
one dad rook Tatum sort of weakens f7 so
also not not so great
alright i played the special g4 stuff
hmm now yeah I'm not quite sure
otherwise I think I've development
issues one point is if he plays age
three now I capture plan knight c6 then
after d 595 which I wouldn't have had if
I were played 96 immediately put white
certainly has a fine position here look
so I could wrap the normal isolated pawn
position where whites got the bishop
pair and good active pieces
so whoopty 11 move I was thinking about
this Queen to b4 which is very concrete
attacking down attacking the bishop if
he moves it to be three then maybe even
my day five sorry phone harassing this
piece but I'm Queen B form you might
like we need to also just just covering
okay so should I play I wrote roof work
to diate for example yeah it looks
normal I'm d5 I still have this 95 yeah
the Sun is also quite normal looking
move stopping the screen now queen
before idea so how to continue here
Trillia not so easy okay let's say okay
let's let's play simple Chettiar my
point of a techie 34 so on what about
the simple move 98 are taking this pawn
and also maybe intending 96 with tempo
and 95 sort of piling up on the deep on
doesn't look too bad before I think I
can I can just grab a three
in 595 d 595 okay so let's uh let's go
for this I'm also just attacking before
now I hope it is really hanging I'm not
but not one hundred percent sure maybe
white has got some some trickier another
idea would have been the movie 62 prefer
to prepare 9725 sort of just blockading
the pawn but very often it's um
dislocating strategy is nice but
somewhat passive so you're just yeah
locating the porn but you're not
actually attacking it and quite often it
is more effective to just attack the
weakness and this is what I'm trying
here attacking the d4 pawn with the rook
bishop tonight so three times attacked
and okay he already feels he needs to
get you need to protect this so 96
possibly 96 wins the temple and maybe
allows me to play Knight to f5 okay you
retreated to be three witches I don't
know 9 at five I've got lots of pieces
attacking the porn how does he actually
cover it and Knight eggs III is also
sort of a yeah half threat not it's not
like our super terrible if i take this
bishop but he needs to be aware of this
possibility okay would open up the FR
rights i need to be cautious but then
general taking the
Twitter quite an idea to get rid of one
of his bishops and maybe weakening its
dark squares we've got opposite colored
bishops then but then this move h3 for
instance and his pawns on a 3d form our
potential targets for the bishop so
taking only three under the right
circumstances can be a very good idea
okay so he advanced to the pawn Fergal
95 he would of course need to move the
Queen and then taking a son quite a
different story uh mr. something else
okay let's let's play this first gaining
a tempo on the Queen and yeah this looks
looks this looks nice now
looks like a pretty a harmonious
position ya hear what actually also
thinking about them 96 winning this
tempo again it may be intending Knight
to c4 what would also be a worth to
consider but wait wait wait wait the Sun
isn't is somewhat isn't as some peace
position somewhat weird here Queen B 5
what about twin b5 Queen B 5 just a text
the bishop on b3 and the night on e 2
how does it protect both and we can
claim we can play moves like night see
one but this is really uncomfortable let
before I can take and Quincy to while
this is Sam after night xe3 its position
Lee terrible okay let's and let's see
what is doing after Queen B 5
maybe you need to play some somewhat
cramped via the TM doesn't want to play
really
yeah maybe even even this light see one
move
I don't really see them another playable
move Quincy to was really are really
looking awful allowing me to take only 3
and damages pawn structure I have a talk
casa night see one is also not a move
that you love to play
yeah maybe you need to otherwise I'll
just just grab material here Quincy
wanna maybe Queens earth Queen see what
new light see one of course yeah I think
he needs to go into two really looks
like rubbish the problem is after Quincy
to I take III and he needs to retake of
course and then I've got em once the
night only five great bishop on g7 and
this points III and d5 are just weak his
he needs to very constantly about those
pieces white for fate still today's
connection alright you disconnected her
this is weird maybe you thought you
really blundered something but I think I
mean I'd see one should should be
playable it's not not too terrible let's
just check this quickly a computer gives
me a slight advantage yeah it's nothing
more I guess let's say let's say here
then um well also root CA decimals rook
c8 an assassin a smooth attending to to
take here and expose oops except post
this Bishop here it's only protected by
the night so maybe
what's the computer actually ah this
move yeah computer move yeah this is
good I didn't see this really ok I take
he takes and then he counted text my
night and this should be as it should be
ok I mean I can take take here and play
a sort of normal move here like like
this and I can try to play on the d5
pawn of course but this is nothing
special what is ok yeah maybe if i don't
know maybe he disconnected really a yet
technically and not as a poor form of
resigning all right i think as short as
it was it was quite interesting too i
think this was was quite quite a good a
good idea attacking this pawn and this
some this looks looks nicer for me
actually in this position Queen B 5
would have been interesting I only had
the idea later but also here would be
interesting how does he protect the
bishop cool cool idea this so this is
this is nice now yeah this song was also
interesting move not sure it's the best
one but pretty pretty interesting way to
increase the pressure but 94 radiesse
sir is the key move which I didn't saw
with dejay which I didn't see also yeah
right thanks for watching short game but
what can you do if people disconnect